if you enjoy playing the Evans gambit
from time to time you came to the right
place
this is a game played in 1963 between a
Bobby Fischer and the number American
Grandmaster the famous Reuben fine who
is also an a dog doctor in psychology
and the university professor Reuben fine
was considered to be a strongest player
in the world one of the strongest
players in the world since 1932 the
1950s and he was actually invited to
play in the World Championship
Tournament in 1948 after the death of
Alexander le Aiken which he declined
unless notice and this is a game played
by the 18-year old Bobby Fischer so nine
years before his big match with Basque
in Reykjavik in 1972 and this is the
game Bobby Fischer is white and the
Reuben fine is black so ii 4 E 5 9 2 s 3
Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 Bishop to c5
and now before Bobby decides to play the
same as Evans gambit Rubin accepts this
challenge
Bishop takes b4 on c3 attacking the
bishop and now Bishop to a5 the Lasker
descents of the emam gambit nowadays
even if someone plays the enemy gambit I
think Bishop d7 is more popular Fischer
plays pawn to d4 II say cb4 Fischer
castles and here Rubin doesn't want to
back down from a challenge in that she
takes another form one takes on c3 and
this is already giving White's too much
development better here is maybe just
development developing with v6 or even
pushing the pawn further to d3 simply
trying to mess up her white piece for
the pieces of ordination
so Bobby play is going to be three and
that is attacking the f7 form means 3/7
attending the forum and our facial
captures night XV 3 and is threatening
Knight to d5 attacking the Queen Rubin
defense nice - s6 and here Bobby plays
nice to d5 attacking the Queen the nice
steaks on eat the bony takes on b5
attacking the knight 95
nice pace 95 Queen takes 75 and Bishop
to b2 and already you can see that white
development is just outstanding and
black doesn't really have anything all
of his bones are in the initial
positions and the queen is attacked
groups are ready to jump in the game and
although black could be somewhat
satisfied as he walked this diagonal
attack from the bishop and the Queen and
bone and the f7 Rubin plays Queen to g5
and here Bobby plays h4 and in this
position this is a very critical
position Rubin should have probably
played a queen b7 and maybe try to hold
it simply blocking those works from
coming to e1 but here it's like it's
like Reuben walnuts be sure to achieve
this greatest victory Indiana and gambit
and the he accepted poncho pawn
sacrifice Queen takes on h4 Bobby plays
Bishop takes on g7 rook the g8 and here
one place rook to e1 check and it
doesn't really matter if the Bishop
captures the rook I mean one the other
rule the come to e1 and things will be
the same so Reuben played King to d8 and
here a very nice station moved by
Fischer or Queen to g3 and in this
position
Reuben fine resigned as the thread is
very simple bishop
the checks after the Queen texts after
the Queen takes the bishop the Queen
will take the rook and it's checkmate
and if the Queen is taken then simply
bishops to f6 check may make immediately
so in this position the only move that
Reuben could play is something like d6
simply giving up a whole queen or maybe
Queen to e7 giving up the Queen this way
but Reuben fine decided it was best it
was best to resign here and give the
chess world an exam this great victory
in the Evans gambit but by the 18
year-old Bobby Fischer so a great game
the gold Fischer and the great
sportsmanship by the old American
Grandmaster Reuben fine like I said if
you're an immense player then you you'll
probably want to remember this image
might occur in your own games so yes
that's the game I hope you enjoyed it
and see you soon